today on the Matt wall show another
Congressional hearing about abortion
this one features liberals refusing to
denounce infanticide refusing to define
the word woman and once again claiming
that men can get pregnant has been a
very instructive spectacle if nothing
else also AOC is the victim of an
outrageous and violent attack after a
comedian mildly heckles her for 10
seconds and a parent at a school board
meeting is told that it would be illegal
to read out loud some of the material
that the school board has approved for
children in their District to read at
school plus Amazon bans me from
advertising my book on its platform
again and car companies are now charging
new subscription fees to access the
features in the vehicle that you already
paid for we'll talk about all that and
more today on the Matt Walsh show
foreign
[Music]
Court decision overturning Roe is a huge
step in the right direction and of
course a long overdue but there's still
a long way to go to rid our country of
abortion and give all unborn children
the right to life that they're
guaranteed by the Constitution did you
know that if you're currently on a phone
plan with one of the major carriers you
may be helping these left-leaning
companies donate to pro-choice causes
and candidates or you may be paying for
their employees travel expenses for
abortions even worse don't let
abortionists use your money to fund
policies and and uh and behavior that
you don't believe in switch to the
pro-life pro-family cell phone company
that I use instead that's Charity mobile
they send five percent of your monthly
plan price to any pro-life charity of
your choice you don't have to compromise
on values or Services because Charity
mobile offers the latest 5G phones no
device or service contracts great
Nationwide coverage and exceptional Live
customer service based right here in the
USA the fight for the right to life
continues and pro-life causes need your
continued support you can help by simply
switching your cell phone service today
to Charity mobile call
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com and mention offer
code walls to redeem the free cell phone
offer that's charitymobile.com and
mention offer code Welsh
two days ago the senate had its hearing
on abortion rights following the
overturning of Roe v Wade during that
hearing we were treated to the spectacle
of the University of California Berkeley
school of law professor Kiara Bridges
attempting to explain to Senator Josh
Hawley that men can get pregnant as we
heard on the on the show yesterday this
exchange was provoked because bridges in
her testimony repeatedly referred to
people with the capacity to get pregnant
rather than simply saying woman and
Holly asked her why she was using this
sort of wordier label and uh and she
said well because because women aren't
the only ones with the capacity to get
pregnant now the funny thing here of
course is that is that people with the
capacity to get pregnant is perhaps the
best possible definition of woman maybe
even better than adult human female
which is the one that I usually go with
I mean they're both true or they're both
accurate but people with the capacity to
get pregnant that's what a woman is
trying to draw a distinction between
people with the capacity to get pregnant
and women and it's like trying to draw a
distinction between the 864 000 mile
wide ball of hot plasma at the center of
our solar system and the sun right the
former is just a a longer way of saying
the latter but Professor Bridges uh
seeks to divorce the word woman from its
inherent definition while still
reserving the right to use the now
meaningless word as if it still has
meaning and those are the the conditions
that created what was at the time maybe
maybe the most absurd and mind-boggling
conversation ever heard in a
congressional hearing that was Tuesday
and that was until yesterday Wednesday
when the House of Representative had its
turn this was a house oversight
Committee hearing on the same subject of
of so-called abortion rights in this
feature testimony from a number of other
pro-abortion Witnesses all competing
with Bridges it seems let's start with
this here is Sarah Lopez who's an
abortion activist describing her own
um experience with abortion listen
what these restrictions are intended to
do is try and make people try and stop
people from having abortions but
abortion is Health Care my abortion was
the best decision I ever made it was an
act of self-love and I'm here today to
make sure that everybody who currently
needs an abortion who has had an
abortion or will need an abortion is not
alone no matter what the state tries to
force upon us
abortion is the best decision she ever
made
I mean it did after all enable her to
become a mediocre nobody in a pant suit
Shilling for abortion
she sacrificed her soul and her child
and in exchange she earned a life so
miserable and pathetic and pointless
that by her own telling her greatest
achievement even still
was paying someone four hundred dollars
to kill her child
she says this is this is a self-love
well it isn't it's selfishness certainly
it's self-centeredness it's
self-involvement it's a lot of
self-words but it's not self-love
because to love is to will the good of
the other to love yourself then is to
will your own good
but through abortion you deprive
yourself of what is good the woman gives
up the joy and fulfillment and goodness
of motherhood for the sake of the
pantsuit believing the lie that these
are mutually exclusive alternatives
she Wills for herself a shallow
regrettable and regretful life of just
misery and loneliness she condemns
herself to an existence spent constantly
rationalizing and defending to the world
but really to herself the awful things
she did in order to open a door that she
knows deep down was not worth the price
of admission
okay that's that's not self-love that is
that's actually self-loathing
disguised as self-love
but there was um more discussion along
these lines of the hearing and uh about
how abortion is an act of love we heard
this from other witnesses as well and
the conversation got darker than that at
one point the same witness Lopez was
asked whether this self-love might
extend to killing babies outside of the
womb infanticide here's how she
responded to that
I assume you agree with infanticide the
killing of a child a perfectly healthy
child at Birth
I don't accept the basis of that
question but I do believe abortion is
Health Care
I'm talking about do you agree I I know
I get that but do you agree I mean are
you in do your support infanticide
killing the child after he's born I do
not agree with the basis of that
question but I believe that abortion is
health care
now she does not agree doesn't agree
with the basis of the question she says
I don't agree with the basis of the
question she treats it like a like a
gotcha question
and yet all she has to do is say no
you can only get got by a question like
that if you refuse to answer it
like if the question should it be legal
to murder
a six-month-old infant if that's a
gotcha question for you then there are
some serious problems with you
for some reason she cannot bring herself
to say no you know just no I I don't
agree with killing infants outside of
the womb can't say it in fact none of
the pro-abortion Witnesses were willing
to express any opposition to the
execution of infants here's another
example
Miss Shannon do you agree with
infanticide well I think you're using
inflammatory language to basically
describe a situation that does not
happen we don't have infanticide
happening doctors would not do that and
neither would folks who have carried
okay what a healthy child do you agree
if a healthy child is born that is that
woman's right to decide if it lives or
dies what I think is based on your
question you have a very low opinion of
pregnant people because if you think
anybody would answer the question excuse
me answer the question I'm answering it
do you know you're not you want it
talking over Witnesses what I'm talking
about you is nobody would carry a
pregnancy and then decide on a Monday
because they are bored that they want to
have an abortion that's ridiculous and
it's inflammatory what you're saying
you're talking about families who are in
tough situations where folks have been
excited about carrying a pregnancy most
of the abortions that happen later in
pregnancy are really tragedies where
it's really a disappointment for
everyone involved but you agree with it
I take it with all those words uh you do
agree with basically murdering a child
after they're born
doctors would not commit infanticide she
says but you know that's not the same
thing as saying that they shouldn't be
able to or that it would be wrong to
also by the way abortionists have
committed infanticide that's why Gosnell
is in jail
and um as you know from this show
activists just a few months ago pro-life
activists uncovered physical evidence of
infanticide in D.C abortion clinics
that's that's going on like right now
though law enforcement never expressed
any interest in following up and
pursuing that lead of course they were
too busy ignoring other crimes it seems
still it does happen
it actually happens a lot
and will certainly happen much more
often especially as abortion activists
are conspicuously hesitant to denounce
the practice
could be an easy win to denounce it you
know if they were to say uh no of course
I don't support that are you crazy what
has got nothing to do with abortion
that's why would you even ask me that
if they were to just answer that way
that would be enough to flip the
question around make the questioner
looks look silly
but they couldn't say that because they
realized that by condemning the killing
of children
a second outside of the womb they will
have fatally weakened the case for
killing kids a second before they emerge
from the womb that's why they know they
can't answer
that's why the question is being asked
also at least one of the one of the
reasons
because if you ask them hey can we kill
a child a second outside of the womb a
minute outside of the womb and if they
say just plainly no of course we can't
do that
well well why can't we do that well
because that's a that's a that's a human
child of course we
well is it not a human child a minute
before
what happened in the minute
what changed in the minute besides the
location of this human child
they know where that's where it's
leading and that's why they can't answer
but we're still not done uh the
Witnesses were and this is now a
tradition I hope
given the opportunity also to define the
word woman as the what is a woman
movement grows and here's how that went
earlier this year our newest Supreme
Court Justice katandra Brown Jackson
was asked what a woman is and she had a
difficult time defining that since you
are the president of the National
Women's Law Center I was hoping that you
could Define what a woman is for us in
this Committee hearing well as the
president of the National Women's Law
Center you can imagine I say woman a lot
in my day job okay so I'm just asking
for the definition
I'm
so and and so what I'll tell you is I am
a woman that's how I identify okay but I
wonder however if in part the reason
that you're asking a question is that
you're trying to suggest that people I'm
simply asking the question and I simply
want an answer and so I think it's
actually really important to be very
clear here that there are people who
identify as non-binary I think okay
about five percent we're not going to go
there I was hoping maybe you would I was
hoping that maybe you would say
something that maybe we learned in um
high school biology that has to do with
X and Y chromosomes but which Define
male and female but I guess we're not
going to get there
you know the amazing thing is that is
that these people by now they must see
this question coming from a mile away
filming the movie what is a woman we had
the advantage of surprise nobody nobody
expected to be asked this stumper of a
question but now they must expect that
especially at a congressional hearing
where just the day before at another
Congressional hearing the most viral
moment revolved around this question so
they have to see it coming
they know it's coming and still
they have not come up with an effective
way to deflect
let alone actually answer the question
but we know they're not going to answer
it but at least you think they come up
with some kind of
if it half effective convincing
deflection they don't even have that
altogether I think these hearings uh
have been quite instructive
and I'm glad they're having them
you know it's the Democrats who wanted
to have these hearings to give their
side a chance to get up there and talk
about how terrible it is now that we're
not going to have Roe v Wade
and I think it's great
to put all of this on full display for
the world to see
you know to see this um these people
leftism
now like a planet out of out of orbit
just like tumbling through the abyss
untethered completely
I think it's a great thing for people to
see
so they can decide whether they want to
follow these people into that Abyss the
liberal Witnesses have just a review
refused to condemn infanticide
they've hailed abortion as an act of
love
they refused to define the word woman
and they've repeatedly claimed that men
can get pregnant
once again the Stark vast unbridgeable
Rift between the two sides is made
evident
a great void separates us
it's not a fracture that can be repaired
it's not it's not a wound that can be
healed at least I don't see how
I don't know if as so many people have
predicted this will all lead to a civil
war but um
if it does
I can certainly Say it'll be the
weirdest civil war in history
but on the bright side you know probably
also the shortest
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
if you're a parent then you know kids
are amazing and also amazingly expensive
but with fabric protecting your family
with term life insurance is surprisingly
affordable fabric was built specifically
for parents to help you manage your
family's financial future like a
parenting Pro stress free Fabrics new
lower prices mean that significant
savings uh that you're going to earn
over other providers with great policies
like a million dollars in coverage for
less than a dollar a day it's hard to
beat that everything is on your schedule
of fabric because it's all online less
than 10 minutes to apply and you can be
offered coverage instantly with no
Health exam required then just
personalize your quote to fit your
family's needs with Fabrics online Hub
it's easy to track your family finances
all in one place get affordable life
insurance set up your kids college
savings plans and even establish a rainy
day savings fund on top of it you can do
all of that with fabric life planning
for the future has never been easier
there's no risk to apply today fabric
has a 30-day money-back guarantee and
you can cancel anytime so protect your
family with term life insurance now in
just 10 minutes apply today at
meetfabric.com Walsh that's
meatfabric.com Walsh to start protecting
your family today m-e-e-t fabric.com
Walsh fabric Insurance Agency policies
issued by vantus life not available in
New York and Montana prices subject to
underwriting and health questions
okay before we get to the headlines I
have to mention again our
new piece of merchandise in the store
that I'm very very proud of and excited
about and I should be wearing it right
now honestly uh the my truth is out
there alien shirts you can show your
support for the space alien Community
there's a lot of great stuff at the Matt
Walsh store if you go to dailywire.com
shop and I was looking through
just right 41 on the air there's there
are things here that I didn't even know
we had I mean I know we have like The
Virtue signal patch which if you don't
have that yet you got to get that to
express your to show your virtue to the
world and it's a good way of just
staying on top of things if you have the
virtue signal patch then you don't have
to rotate between you know the Ukraine
flag and the pride flag and the the
current thing you just got it all
covered with the virtue signal patch or
The Virtue signal t-shirt which we have
we of course have the the chef shelf
Chef self pronouns apron
um so you can let people know your
pronouns while you're cooking out on the
grill
and then I didn't even realize we had
now officially the Sweet Baby Baby
Onesie so if you have if you're
welcoming a new bundle of joy into the
world and you want to indoctrinate them
as you should into the sweet baby gang
cult early on you can get in this
onesies there's a lot of great stuff go
to dailywire.com shop and see it all
there okay
congresswoman Alexandra Casa Cortez was
confronted
um on the steps of the Capitol in what
I'm sure she would describe and maybe
has already described as an act of
insurrection she was confronted by Alex
Stein who is a conservative a comedian a
you know social media personality we
played a number of his videos on this
show before this confrontation though
was a little bit
it was a little bit unique
it's not what you usually see but let's
let's watch it here it is
AOC my favorite big booty latina I love
you ASC you're my favorite
she wants to kill babies but she's still
beautiful you look very beautiful in
that dress you look very sexy look at
that booty on AOC that's my favorite big
booty latina
I love it my favorite AOC nice to meet
you AOC look how sexy she looks in that
dress
hot hot like a tamale
so
there you go that's how that
conversation went
um now AOC is is of course picking this
up and running with it here's what she
tweeted actually it's pretty funny she
tweeted at first there's a string of
tweets here so last night at around 8 30
um she tweeted
let me see how I pulled this up she
tweeted
I posted about a deeply disgusting
incident that happened today on the
capital steps but took it down because
it's clearly someone seeking extremist
Fame it's just a bummer to work in an
institution that openly allowed this but
talking about it only invites more just
really sad okay so she says I don't want
to call attention to this so uh I don't
want to I don't want to give this person
more Fame and so she just she posted
about it then she deleted then she
posted again but and then another 15
minutes goes by and she just can't help
herself she posts the video herself with
this guy's face right there after just
saying I don't want to give more
attention to this guy she just can't she
can't help herself because you know why
because this is attention to her and
it's also an opportunity to make herself
into a victim she knows that the smarter
move would just be to not acknowledge it
at all don't bring attention to it
hardly anybody will see it and then you
move on with your like she knows that
but you can see this internal conflict
and you can just imagine the torturous
15 min minutes between that first tweet
and the follow-up when she finally
posted the video herself which was going
back and forth
you know devil and angel on the shoulder
well they're both Devils for her but one
is slightly more reasonable telling her
don't post the video she's like no I
can't it's just it's a tension I have to
and so she finally posted and she says
here is a video he posted of the
incident I was actually walking over to
deck him because if no one will protect
us then I'll do it myself but I needed
to catch a vote more than a case today
right
she uh she was gonna she was a
girlfriend decum I don't want to catch a
case though I was going to beat this guy
up
yet what does she do she goes over and
gives the peace sign and like mugs for
the camera uh I was gonna deck him for
it but instead I just went along with it
and posed for a selfie instead
now if we can get past how pathetically
hilarious it is the we're supposed to
take her seriously that she was gonna go
deck somebody
um she is though threatening violence
against a comedian
for heckling her
and she's also saying that um she
thinks it should be illegal
for people to say rude things there
that's what she says
she says it's a bummer to work an
institution that allows this so she's
saying this should not be allowed you
should not be allowed to approach me
as a politician and say things to me
that I find offensive you shouldn't be
allowed to do it she says and she needs
to be protected from it
she needs to be protected from people
saying big booty latina to her
now that's an interesting perspective
let's let's go back and remember let's
go back to ancient history which was
just like I don't know five days ago
and remember what she said after
Kavanaugh uh justice Kavanaugh was
harassed by leftist militants while he
was um at a restaurant with his family
here's what here was her response to
that okay so we saw her response to when
she's getting harassed what about when
Kavanaugh's getting harassed she says
poor guy he left before his souffle
because he decided half the country
should risk death if they have an
ectopic pregnancy within the wrong state
lines it's all very unfair to him the
least they could do is let him eat cake
so that's our response when other people
are being harassed in fact AOC has
defended mobs that show up at the homes
of Supreme Court Justice she has no
problem with um you know any kind of
aggressive harassment or intimidation
tactic used against her opponents
famously
looting and rioting she has that she's
she has openly defended
now she wants us to feel sorry for her
because someone said big booty latina to
her no too bad AOC no sympathy for me
sorry
you openly advocate for your wit for
your enemies to be harassed and then
you're offended
and you wanted to treat it like a crime
when it happens to you
I say again nope sorry
you want this world congresswoman now
you get it have fun
something else that AOC by the way has
said is that um protests
are supposed to make you uncomfortable
she said this multiple times that um and
this is her way of excusing again
rioting looting people showing people's
houses
uh protesters remember the when the
protesters followed
Kristen Cinema into the bathroom
followed her she went into a bathroom
stall and harassing her on camera
did AOC come out and condemn that no she
didn't
why because because protesting is
supposed to make you uncomfortable
well made her uncomfortable to be called
a big booty latina That was supposed
isn't that what the protesting is
supposed to accomplish now does this
video count as a protest was he actually
protesting her
like in his way he was he starts off by
saying she wants to kill babies he's
obviously what he's doing is he's he's
heaping disrespect and Scorn on her as
an act of protest as a statement you can
agree or disagree with that approach
that's what he's doing now if it were me
um that's not what I would be saying to
her
I certainly wouldn't be saying anything
nice but that's not where I would go
but the point is that again these are
the rules that she established
and as conservatives we really have to
stop trying to protect these these
people from suffering the consequences
of their own choices
from being held to their own standards
for being forced to play by the rules
that they have established
we can't try to Shield somebody from
what comes after them once they tear
down all the fences you know what it's
like
as especially these conservatives and
there have been some today that have
come to her defense and say oh this you
know Bob this is this is too far this is
inappropriate I don't like AOC but this
is my condemn this I condemn it
you know what it's like
it's exactly like
if somebody came along
and tore down a fence
knowing there's a rabid dog on the other
side of it and they tore it down because
they want the dog to tear you to pieces
but instead the dog turns around and
mauls them
now if that were to happen would you
look and say oh that's unfortunate
that's really terrible it's a terrible
thing so you'd say Well it serves you
right that's that's Justice you tore
down a fence hoping a dog would attack
someone else would attack you that's
that is justice is what that is
what else am I supposed to call that am
I supposed to feel sorry for you you
wanted this thing to Maul me to death
and instead it's it's chomping on your
leg and I'm supposed to feel sorry
how self-loathing would I have to be how
much would I have to hate myself to
sympathize with you in that circumstance
this woman just to reiterate again she
has no problem sicking mobs of dangerous
militants on the homes of people she
doesn't agree with even after she she
defended these the people harassing
Kavanaugh even after someone showed up
to Kavanaugh's house with a gun planning
to kill him
and she was still saying yeah go after
him it's fine uh poor little baby
and now she's crying because someone
said big booty latina and they're
actually conservative so I know this is
too far this is too far
give me a break
although I will say um even if I don't
sympathize with AOC because she's an
attention-starved hypocrite getting a
dose of her own medicine
I I do think actually that it was
objectively inappropriate to call her a
big booty latina
um the proper term is big booty latinx
or latinx
shameful oversight there Alex Steiner
should be ashamed
all right let's move to this from the
New York Post
um it says a Florida father is speaking
out after a school board cut off his
microphone as he denounced pornographic
material in classrooms claiming somebody
failed drastically in the mission to
protect young minds uh Bruce Friedman is
his name he's the Florida Chapter
president of no left turn in education
which works to restore parental function
in public education he was silenced
during a June 30th Clay County School
District board meeting as he read from a
book he found that the Fleming Island
high school
and this exchange is just one you have
to see for yourself so let's play it
um tonight I'm going to give a sampling
from three books that are in our
libraries at the Fleming School and the
Oak Leaf School
and then we can discuss you can discuss
the process by which these books get on
the shelves because there's a Clay
County employee that got paid to put
this book lucky
Alice the Bold
I'm going to read things if there's
children watching
cover their ears he began to I'm gonna
stop you right there sir I'm gonna stop
you right there started his fingers
fingers turn the microphone off turn off
his microphone please
I've told you I'm stopping you
the reason I'm stopping you is because
these meetings are if you'll hush your
mouth for a minute and listen instead of
just talking you really learn something
the problem is Sir is these meetings are
broadcast there are people at home that
are watching it on YouTube they're
people that are watching it on community
television are you going to listen are
you going to run your mouth
exploding my time
and you'll get it back but you'll get it
back to talk about something besides
reading pornography into a public
television set
well
let me explain something to you
there are federal and state laws that
prohibit you from saying the things that
you're getting ready to say on
television
there are state laws that private and
Federal Communications laws that
prohibit you from publishing these
things to a child
you don't have the you don't have the
ability at this point to determine who's
watching the television show and for you
to say everybody cover your ears just
doesn't cut it if you go to
if if you go to
television and you look before anything
that comes on that's offensive they have
it great it is are
nc17 PG or G or X now
if if you put something on the
television without that you are
violating state and federal law number
one number two if you'll hush them in
and listen you'll learn something
wow
uh first of all
this is really another reason why
um even though the two incidents are not
directly related another reason why I
don't have any problem with
the someone calling AOC a big booty
latinx is that um because it's like it's
disrespect but these people I'm just
lumping them all together you know the
people running school boards AOC they're
all in the same camp
they have no respect for us whatsoever
they just they you know what you want to
talk about scorn but scoring they Heap
on us every
a second of the day and you hear it in
that Exchange
you want to shut your mouth for a minute
who are you talking to
I thought the guy that was trying to
speak he he kept his calm better than I
probably could I respect that and um in
the process he Illustrated something
very important
but pardon me which is he had respond
like who the hell are you talking to you
son of a [ __ ] why don't you shut your
mouth
if you tell it who do you think you are
that you could sit up there and tell me
to close my mouth that's not how this
works you sit on a school board you're a
nobody you work for me
I tell you to shut your mouth and listen
to me
that should be the response and and what
is he saying um it's it's illegal
this guy is saying it's illegal
to read this material out loud because a
child might hear it meanwhile this is
the material that he allows to be in the
schools that he oversees so it's illegal
for a parent to read it out loud at a
school board meeting but it's not
illegal to supply it to the kids in the
in the library at the school
just in incredible
and this brings me back to a point that
should be reiterated
um I said yesterday that you shouldn't
be sending your kid into the university
system not the first time I've said that
uh you know how I feel about the public
school system because of stuff like this
okay because of the the
indoctrination that goes on the content
that that kids in these schools are
subjected to uh the messages and
everything else and also the people
running these institutions
and I got pushed back yesterday as I
have many times in the past from people
saying as we were talking specifically
in that case about the university system
but I hear it also about the public
school system when I say get out of the
public school system homeschool your
kids and all the rest of it the pushback
that I get is that um well no that's
that's cowardly that's where we're
giving up right we're uh you we can't do
that we need to fight for these
institutions we have to reclaim and
fight for these institutions rather than
abandon them
but but here's the problem we can't
okay you can't reclaim them as they are
currently constructed they have to be
destroyed and rebuilt the public school
system the fact that something like that
can even happen at a school board
meeting
everything from the tone the school
board member is taking the way he's
speaking to the other guy and and the
the what they're talking about
everything about it
the fact that that a school board member
will sit there and say it's illegal for
you to read this out loud but we can
still give it to your kids
you know that just shows that the rot
in the school system goes all the way
down it's at a structural level this is
like
you know if you're buying an old
dilapidated home and you might think at
first well you could do a nice Remodel
and then you look at it and you see no
there's structural damage this thing is
beyond saving has to be demolished okay
we need to remodel this thing with a
wrecking ball which is how we need to
remodel the the public school system
metaphorically speaking and and then and
then rebuild something completely
different that's the only answer
um the answer is not
to try and take over the left's
institutions as they are currently
constructed because they are the less
institutions they own them and as long
as you are inside them you're at their
Mercy
abandon the institutions to the extent
that you can't build your own and you
can do that with education too
you know homeschooling may not seem like
an institution but it actually is there
are and as as homeschooling parents
we've been involved in several of them
there are you know you can get together
as a community of homeschoolers and
build your own co-ops build your own
um in effect your own small scale
educational system so it's not just you
you know taking the burden of um of of
this all on your own you don't have to
do that
so that's the answer
and then once we've abandoned these as
institutions you don't even need the
wrecking ball because they'll collapse
on their own
okay the public school system they in
order to survive it needs your children
it can't survive without the feeds okay
it's like a it's a parasite that feeds
on your kids
and then the other the other point that
I always have to
um make sure it emphasizes that when it
comes to education you know you talk
about oh we need to fight for we need to
fight for the institutions well if you
send your kid to public school
or to a liberal University for that
matter you are not fighting to reclaim
that institution you're not you're not
doing the fighting you're not doing
anything you're just sending your kid
off your child is the one who you are
tasking to to to wage this war okay
you're sending your kid in and when
especially when it comes to the public
school system that is an insane strategy
like it's hard enough for parents to
deal with these people you're going to
send your seven-year-old in and say
fight for this institution
asking way too much of your child if you
do that I think all right you know we
can always rely on as we move on we can
always rely on this guy to make
compelling arguments and to get right to
the heart of the matter so here is
Senator Chris Murphy of Connecticut
um tweeting after in response to the new
footage that came out of the Uvaldi
police department and how they were
cowering in the hallways while uh
children were being executed on the
other side of an unlocked door that
never tried to open Chris Murphy though
he says the Uvaldi video puts to bed
forever the question of whether the way
to deal with bad guys with guns is to
make sure there are more good guys with
guns we've always known it was a gun
industry created lie designed to sell
more guns now we just have the
gut-wrenching proof
so think about the logic here
first of all he's saying
these men with guns were cowards and
they failed in their Duty that part is
correct
but he says which proves forever that no
man has ever or will ever use a gun to
protect himself or anyone else
so footage of men with guns who are
supposed to be the good guys failing in
their Duty that proves that there has
never ever been a good guy with a gun
who has actually lived up to his duty
and acted courageously and there could
never be one in the future
because of this one tragedy
I guess that's about the lot the sort of
logic that you would expect from the
males can give birth crowd but also the
ill logic goes one level deeper because
what is he actually saying what's the
implication he's saying that
um you can't trust the cops take
to protect you the good guy with a gun
thing is a myth and that and that also
applies to the cops he says
doesn't exist
and so give up your guns
so that you'll have to rely totally on
the cops to protect you
good guy with a gun is a myth can't rely
on the cops to protect you
therefore give up your guns
and if the bad guys ever come after you
rely on the cops to protect you even
though you can't and it's a myth that
they will so this is this is what we get
from the uh from this crowd all right
a couple other things to mention here uh
daily wire says the everything store
appears to have a double standard when
it comes to gender identity content
Amazon recently rejected the daily wires
paid ads for Matt Walsh's book what is a
woman saying the ads contain prohibited
content the company cited a policy
Banning content that questions a
person's sexual orientation
an Amazon advisors support uh wrote in
an email to daily wire we don't allow
content that appears to infer or claim
uh to diagnose treat reverse or question
sexual orientation
it's a strange rationale the article
continues what a woman is not about
sexual orientation as much as gender
identity and the radical Progressive
ideology around it yeah I mean this just
makes this of course makes no sense at
all actually
um yeah the book doesn't deal with
sexual orientation at all that's that is
not the subject of the book
and as far as sexual orientation goes
you know as as the the transgender
agenda gender ideology runs roughshod
over um over what was in the past the
leftist agenda especially as it pertains
to feminists like we've talked about
this week it also does this with um you
know with so-called gay rights because
like sexual orientation doesn't even
really mean anything anymore if your
gender doesn't mean anything
and also if it is as we've been told you
know your sexual orientation is
immutable it cannot be changed
this is one of the this has always been
or at least when I say always for the
last you know a couple of decades anyway
on the left this has been one of the
number one most sacrosanct Creeds that
your your sexual orientation is set in
stone you're born with it and it can
never change well um if that's the case
then you can also it all it's also
impossible to change your gender because
if you can change your gender that means
you can change your sexual orientation
you know if you're a gay man attracted
to men because that means you're a gay
man and then you become a woman and
you're still attracted to men well that
means your sexual orientation has
changed so that's just yet another
inherent contradiction created by gender
ideology
um but so so what is Amazon doing here
um they they realize they can't justify
Banning the book because the that's what
they would like to do they'd like to ban
the book outright and say you can't sell
this book on our site but uh they do
have their own guidelines which they've
published and everybody can read and
they realize that according to those
guidelines the book doesn't violate any
of them now of course it doesn't make
sense
that you know if that the book is so
hateful that and violates policies and
so you can ban advertising but you also
but you still but but by according to
your own guidelines you can't just ban
the book out right like if it
if it if it violates the standards for
advertising then you think it also
violates the standards for being sold on
the site at all so that doesn't make a
lot of sense
but um I think this is just kind of
the compromise Amazon has come up with
especially to appease their own woke
employees who infamously have been you
know literally crying about the books
that I've published on their site Amazon
realizes that they can suppress and
censor the book in certain ways
without drawing a lot of backlash and
negative publicity so they're going as
far as they can without making it into a
story and they realize that censoring
the ads for whatever reason isn't a
story Banning the book out right is a
story and so uh that's that's what
they're doing that's that's the
compromise they've come up with all
right
one other thing
to mention before we get to the comment
section
um
from the New York Post a very important
report
so as a woman in a now viral Tick Tock
video climbed through a McDonald's
drive-through window to get to the
kitchen so she could cook the food
herself the clip foot posted by the user
Greer Greer said that um because the
fast food company the fast food
employees ran out of gloves they could
not take any more orders due to sanitary
concerns so then she just asked if she
could climb through the window and make
the food herself and I guess they let
her do it let's watch this this video
lady climbs through McDonald's window
because we're not taking any more orders
cause we have no gloves
she's not playing she wants to make her
own food
[Applause]
[Music]
um
it's my first day training and I came
unactly dressed so you are not held
responsible for my birthday she clapping
and all
[Applause]
what are you doing what is it
okay so she's clearly drunk um climbing
through the drive-through window as one
does this is something drunk people
apparently do part of the culture
but here's where the focus should really
be
they aren't taking orders because they
ran out of gloves
what but you can't just wash your hands
have you heard it do you have soap and
water back there
or send someone out to get more gloves
or a check ahead of time to make sure
that you have enough gloves to get
through the night shift
it seems like there are any number of
solutions that would have worked both
before and after this problem arose
instead there are you could see in the
video there are like 57 employees there
they can't claim to be understaffed
there's this whole gaggle of employees
just kind of standing around still on
the clock
but but telling everyone how you can't
make your food we're just gonna sit here
we're on the clock wow yeah we can't do
anything for you sorry
I swear people will come up with any
excuse these days to not work
I am uh I I told you about my the the
story from Chipotle going in and being
told that they can only take online
orders but they can they can't listen to
my order they can't listen with their
ears as I speak the order but if I were
to type it into my phone then they can
take it just find another excuse not to
work I'm expecting to go to Burger King
one of these days and be told that they
aren't serving anymore because
all of the employees simultaneously
stubbed their toes and they're taking a
week off to recover from the damage
just kidding of course I would never go
to Burger King I do have some soft
respect uh let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
you know every day I report the
ludicrous just insane stuff the left is
doing to our children drag queen story
hours underage and irreversible sex
changes even grooming that goes goes on
we here at the Matt wall show humbly
inform the nation of the less agenda
every day but I'm thrilled to report
that there's an organization taking
action to finally push back on all of
this woke Madness and filth that's the
American principles project it's a
Grassroots political advocacy group that
is uh mobilizing the Grassroots and
pressuring states in the federal
government to stop LGBT Insanity you can
sign up today at
savethefamily.app again that's
savethefamily.app if you've ever
listened to our show and wondered what
you can do to stop the destruction of
our country what actual actions can you
take what uh what what plan can you put
in place this is your chance to fight
back the work of the American principal
project has resulted in 18 states
banning men from women's sports it's
even pressured so-called conservatives
in Congress to get off their butts and
pass pro-family platform planks they
also Target some of the worst
programming Democrats in the country
working to defeat really Sinister creeps
like uh Michigan Governor Gretchen
Whitmer or self-proclaimed Georgia
Governor Stacy Abrams for the same price
look as a Disney Plus subscription you
can join the American principles project
and directly fight back against the left
grooming agenda I highly encourage all
of my listeners to visit
savethefamily.app this is a great
organization again that's
savethefamily.app visit the site sign up
and help win the war on the groomers
today
Barry Bishop says related to the guy who
lost friends over your movie my
childhood best friend of 15 years just
decided she can't talk to me unless I
change my views on abortion and LGBT
this doesn't make much sense to me
because we hardly ever talk about
politics when together has this ever
happened to you Matt if so how did you
get over it
uh yeah I mean there are definitely
plenty of people who don't talk to me
anymore uh in in recent years
and then there was another just over
over the years as I've been doing this
for a living just people have dropped
off
and uh have dropped off of the tree here
and then especially over the last month
there's been even more silence
and um
how do I deal with it I deal with it by
being
a
a Hermit at heart who has absolutely no
problem not talking to people anymore
it's like to me it's not I'm not saying
it's the best way to be psychologically
or the most healthy way
but when people say I'm not going to
talk to you anymore okay great that's
just one less person I have to talk to
that's fine I'm totally fine with that
but if you're a normal like
psychologically healthy well-adjusted
person how do you deal with it I
unfortunately I can't I can't give
advice from that perspective because
that's not my own lived experience
Jesse says Matt is such a dad Persona
makes him a great SPG Dad too sometimes
when he talks to us in the gang and he's
being all down to earth all real and
Common Sense sounding it feels like
sitting down to a dad lesson to educate
and prepare his kids for dealing with
the world
you know it is a very strange thing
because when I first had kids
I felt very out of place
and I think every parent goes through
this when you're when you first have
kids feel very out of place you know
referring to myself as a dad was just
was weird
my first Father's Day I felt like an
imposter like I didn't earn this it just
how am I the one celebrating Father's
Day
um but then one day you look up and you
can't conceive of yourself anymore as
anything but a parent
so now it's like my defining trait as
you say so it's a that is uh that's how
life Works another dad lesson for you
game time says the much funnier approach
to the JK Rowling thing would be to
apologize for her and praise the fact
that she's a staunch Ally and is only
saying these things to deflect criticism
then thank her for her support the media
will instantly latch on to it no matter
what she says thank her for her staunch
allegiance to your cause that would be
some Next Level trolling toward not only
her but the media as well they wouldn't
be able to help themselves that would be
the funny thing to do but you know
things I actually do respect
um how she's stood up against the trans
mob throwing me to the wolves and under
the bus all at the same time I don't
really respect that as much but
anyone who stands up against the mob
especially the trans mob in particular I
I just I respect that and so even if she
hates my guts and she does I still
respect it so I'm not actually trying to
cause problems for her I'm not gonna
back down either but I'm not going to go
out of my way to create issues for her
so this is what I've I've settled on
um
let's see midna says
I'm sorry to inform you Matt but you're
kind of wrong on something you can in
fact sue a manufacturer for misuse LOL
pretty sure I just heard recently a
woman got an STD or something while
having sex in a vehicle and sued the
manufacturer and won it's insane but it
happens for some reason
um actually I have to fact check your
fact check here midnight you need to use
you need to do your research into STD
STD and car related issues uh the woman
did not Sue the car manufacturer she
actually went after the insurance
company
the insurance company that covered the
car in which she had her sexual
uh interaction
she had so she had sex with a guy in his
uh I think it was his Hyundai
and of course and she contracted genital
warts and then she filed a claim saying
that his car insurance company Geico
should compensate her for it and I think
the court actually sided with her to the
tune of like five million dollars
so this could lead to a very interesting
ad campaign with the Geico Gecko
you know I it is because this is a this
is a certain customer base if you're you
know the kind of person who
has sex in the vehicle and you're going
to pass on various STDs then we've got
you covered we need the Geico Gecko out
there to explain that to us although the
whole thing is of course it's ridiculous
on a number of levels I don't think I
need to explain why starting with the
fact that any rational person would know
ahead of time
that you're going to get genital warts
if you have sex with a guy in a Hyundai
like that's
so another type of car you know we could
talk but uh but uh Hyundai is a you know
what do you expect everybody knows that
if you want to make something more
valuable all you have to do is uh raise
the price of it right just just like
that just slap on a higher price tag and
it's as simple as that you have luxury
bread designer gas exclusive squares of
toilet paper soon every home with
groceries electricity will be the Envy
of its neighborhood sounds familiar
right well the other way to create value
is to offer people something that they
really want and then charge them a fair
price for it I think this is the way
this is the better way I prefer this way
so if you still haven't heard maybe
because you were listening to Jill Biden
comparing Latinos to uh tacos uh then
maybe you were distracted from the fact
that Dr Jordan Peterson has joined us at
Daily wire plus right now just eight
dollars a month gives you access to the
full sum of Jordan Peterson's outrageous
intellect including Dragons monsters and
men a four-part mini-series on men
masculinity and the pursuit of greatness
it's great stuff you have to watch it
um I feel greater just talking about it
not to mention everything else we're
doing with daily wire plus to unwoke the
country through Fearless documentaries
gripping movies and coming soon we're
also going to have kids content you
don't want to miss any of that to take
advantage of our Eight dollar a month
special membership offer go to
dailywireplus.com today and use code
plus I got to get used to saying
dailywireplus.com that's
dailywireplus.com right now or go buy a
gallon of Biden's designer gasoline
totally up to you I think I know which
one you should choose now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
cancellation I'm going to harp on
something seemingly very small and Petty
um that is after all what this segment
was always supposed to be about even if
I have on occasion betrayed the spirit
of the daily cancellation by talking
about topics that actually matter I will
not make that mistake today although I
do believe as I'll explain that this
issue is a microcosm of a larger and
more pervasive cultural problem and here
it is
BMW speaking of cars
we'll be charging a subscription fee
for giving genital warts to people in
your car no for for using the heated
seats in some of their vehicles there's
going to be a subscription fee if you
want to use the heated seats in their
vehicles now I have no dog directly in
this fight I don't own a BMW I'll never
own one I prefer for my cars to be 100
American made
uh and unfortunately those kinds of cars
don't exist so I try to settle for at
least like 52 percent American made God
Bless the USA
but even if I'm not a BMW customer I I
still am annoyed by this news as
reported by the daily wire it says BMW
owners are Furious that on top of the
cost of the luxury car they'll be
required to pay a monthly subscription
fee to use features like the heated
seats per the New York Post subscription
plans recently rolled out in the UK
Germany South Korea and in several other
markets which include fees for premium
features BMW owners will be forced to
pay the equivalent of 18 bucks a month
to use heated front seats in their cars
owners also have the option to pay 180
per year to use their heated seats or
they can opt to spend 300 for a
three-year subscription or 415 dollars
for unlimited access the publication
reported quote front seat heating gets
things nice and cozy and no time BMW's
UK site says activation after purchase
is quick and easy heated seats aren't
the only premium feature with an up
charge and some markets owners will pay
12 dollars per month to use their heated
steering wheels it'll cost 42 dollars
per month for adaptive cruise control
the feature that switches off high beams
automatically when another car appears
also costs 12 monthly anyone wants to
connect their iPhones to their cars
through Apple's carplay feature will be
charged 265 dollars
now this is not something that's
confined only to BMWs in foreign
countries as an article this week and
The Verge points out cars today are
packed full of software systems and
computers and this fact is being
exploited more and more by the
manufacturers The Verge reports quote
most of the subscription plans seem to
be coming mainly from luxury automakers
which makes sense given that their
customers are mostly rich and can more
easily absorb an annual or monthly fee
but industry analysts have said the
subscriptions are coming to mass-market
Vehicles as mainstream automakers look
for new revenue streams to help fund
their enormously expensive plans to
build vehicles that are electric
connected and autonomous last year
General Motors said it earned over two
billion dollars in in-car Subscription
Service Revenue a number of the company
expects to grow to 25 billion by the end
of the decade GM had approximately 16
million vehicles on the road in the US
about a quarter of which include
features which customers are paying
subscriptions quote our Research
indicates that with the right mix of
compelling offerings customers are
willing to spend 135 dollars per month
on average from products and services
according to one of the guys at GM okay
now here's here's a skipping hit here's
why I hate this
first of all
it's not as though you're paying less
for the car if you don't want the extra
features this isn't like a spirit's
Spirit Airlines thing where you pay for
the standard no-frill service where they
just throw you in the cargo hold and
airdrop you over your destination with a
parachute made out of a tarp or they can
give you the option to pay extra for the
luxury of a seat and a seat belt or an
oxygen mask that's not what's happening
with these vehicle subscription fees
that's not the case if you purchase a
BMW in one of these markets you already
have the heated seeds it's built into
the car they already made it you bought
it you have it
which means you paid for it the
manufacturer is double dipping forcing
you to pay twice for the same feature so
they sell you the car with the heated
seats but then they install a software
to block your access to it unless you
pay an additional recurring fee
it's a kind of uh out in the open
extortion companies openly and just like
shamelessly bilking their customers as
we grow ever more accustomed to be
treated this way
one wonders how far it will go perhaps
soon you'll have to pay a small fee
every time you use your windshield
wipers or your turn signal
maybe you'll need to subscribe for
monthly access to your vehicle's braking
system
oh sorry you had a you got a new debit
card and forgot to update your payment
method uh so they've had to temporarily
disable your brakes unfortunately you're
learning about this while going 75 on
the highway sorry about your luck
this is the Glorious benefit that we
enjoy when all of our consumer products
are smart not just cars of course but
increasingly almost all of our consumer
products are filled with software
computer programs they're connected to
the internet
you don't even have a choice anymore
we moved last year and we bought a bunch
of new appliances
and um you know I didn't really need a
washing machine with its own Twitter
account that's what we ended up with I
don't need to be able to connect with my
dishwasher through an app on my phone
but I can
I don't need to be able to adjust my
refrigerator's internal temperature
while I'm a thousand miles away I don't
need to be able to remotely monitor my
crock pot but that's that's basically
what I end up with
and the more connected and computerized
we make all of these products the more
fragile they are the more unreliable
and the less we're able to control and
understand and fix them ourselves
as many people have remarked upon the
great irony of Modern Life is that our
products are getting smarter and we are
getting dumber and this is all by Design
another great advantage of the design
Advantage for the for the companies that
make and sell this stuff anyway
certainly not for the consumers is that
the connect the connectivity of all
these things
um the fact that every consumer product
is now a device
means of the brands can track us and
they can monitor us and they can collect
our information and sell the information
they can stay connected to us in ways
that don't benefit us at all
they can monetize us long after the
initial point of purchase
but here's the worst thing about all
this stuff
the more the manufacturers can stay
connected to and in control over the
things that we ostensibly own
the more that ownership becomes
subscription based
the less ownership we actually
experience
see there's a there's a war on ownership
in our culture the powers that be they
don't want you to actually possess and
own anything
they want you to buy a lot of stuff they
want you to fill your homes with branded
material Goods
but they don't want you to actually own
any of it
everything's on loan
so many Americans live now in rented
homes or apartments they drive Finance
cars filled with subscription-based
features they buy everything on credit
and they own nothing
this is simply not how human beings are
meant to live we're meant to take
ownership
of something of our own small piece of
existence
so we can lay down our roots and say
this is mine this belongs to me
it is a natural and good human desire
which we so often suppress
so that we can live in other people's
homes on other people's land using
products that still belong to the
companies we bought them from
we own nothing instead we are owned
and that is why BMW's heated seats
feature is canceled
I told you I told you I was going to
make a mountain out of mobile
I followed through on the promise and
I'll do it for us today thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
show is produced by Sean Hampton
executive producer Jeremy boring our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
production manager Pavel vadosky our
associate producer is McKenna Waters
shows edited by Jeff Tomlin Our audio is
mixed by Mike cormina hair makeup is
done by Cherokee heart the Matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2022. John Bickley
here daily wire editor-in-chief wake up
every morning with our show morning wire
where we bring you all the news that you
need to know in 15 minutes or less join
me and my co-host Georgia Howe for daily
coverage of all the biggest stories on
morning wire
foreign
[Music]